então hoje eu queria vir aqui mostrados
como é que nós conseguimos criar vários
golpes em várias áreas na neste mundo da
engenharia e que anos atrás como é que
os biomateriais conseguem ter um papel
na prevenção do cancro gástrico
então é demais o investigador do minério
que achei todas review américa que o
centena segundo fugiu com um empate no
olímpico com um evento desse ano no
instituto um grande instituto de
investigação em saúde que houve
tragédias
ele tem um novo edifício mesmo aqui a
lenta e para vos mostrar que eles têm
mesmo conectar vários docs é nós neve
temos entre los no todo várias possíveis
e imaginárias na cae por isso é bom
vocês pensarem que quando tira um curso
a formação é uma base para depois
explorar em conseguirem juntar voz entre
as todos e ligarem no fundo aprofundarem
as várias poças gostam e estas são umas
das principais áreas em que nós
trabalharmos hoje vamos falar um carimbo
quarto na realidade antes da
nanomedicina questão de materiais todos
vocês certeza absoluta sabem a gente não
pensar muito nisso samba criado os lados
em contato com os sistemas biológicos
que o nosso corpo e que são os azuis
então para diagnosticar tratar ou
substituir qualquer parte do nosso corpo
o bce de um órgão ou a uma função porque
aí tem aqui vários fizemos com 10 anos
poluentes contato com razão oficial taça
da liga
vários biomas e acho que todos vocês já
ouviram falar mas nós queremos provar
sua necessidade de resolver um problema
importante e com alex
não sei se já ouviram falar nesta
bactéria chamas ela vai até pylori e em
festa 50 por cento da população mundial
a cair
ou seja vocês podem mandar a pessoa que
estava do nosso lado e
11 você acha parte está infectado
aliás nem vai falar em portugal a taxa
de infecção em da manhã cerca de 80 a 90
por cento das pessoas acrescenta se uma
coisa só nove estão enfrentado sair e
não é o que acontece
não é toda a gente que está enfeitada
com esta bactéria que vai desenvolver
cancro verso e ontem apenas 1% das
pessoas que está enfeitado falando que o
placar com o desenvolvimento tem lugar
no entanto passa estamos a falar de um
problema a nível mundial por isso existe
muita gente que tem uma uma propensão
para desenvolver qualquer lugar vivo
esta empresa ou seja das pessoas que têm
sintomas e que acabam por isso ao médico
acabam por ter a indicação para
erradicar até o tratamento normal comum
é fazer isso aconteça com antibióticos
fica um inibidor da lama do próprio não
por volta das 18h e devem falar fica aí
o que acontece em 23 anos dessas pessoas
num tratamento é eficaz nelas ou seja
continuamos com cerca de 140 milhões de
pessoas no mundo inteiro que não tem
nenhum tratamento outra natureza podem
arrancar esta matéria
então tá no stonehenge sabendo que a
bactéria para se ligar ao nosso estômago
liga havia umas luzinhas que a própria
bactéria que vocês vêem aqui tem uma
usina com água especificamente nos
açúcar acho que nós temos no caso do
nosso estômago
então o que nós pensávamos usava
material 1 bilhão material que possa ser
administrada oralmente e que tem alguns
desses conceitos hoje velho acho que nós
temos o nosso estômago para chegar lá
ele garantiu que teria então a nossa
tecnologia e os anos 70 mas suas
ligações específicas e até a bactéria
isso caxito
então surgiu então um projeto em
ligando docs várias instituições e por
isso foi um projeto em parceria com o
neve ou 4 ciências e um empate no minuto
em que desenvolvemos então umas pequenas
férias que podem ser tomadas por via
oral
chegam a tomar a idéia é incluir em
bactérias que estão lá 300 usadas tais
açúcar específicos para elas - nós temos
um estorno e depois as bactérias possam
ser removidas pelo trato
gastrointestinal na entreajuda então
candidato como é que esta história foi
ruindo então qual foi a estratégia então
usamos um polímero a cair natural que é
o quinto ano e possa estar lá alunos
possa levar um chapéu já que os alunos
de engenharia por meio de outras pessoas
que não sabem que isso é mas então o que
dizer um clipe natural que pode ser
encontrado em várias fontes na final dos
leves provém do governo do df da lua não
sei se você chame cozinheiro não são
hoje um gancho vinha mas sujar
cozinharam aula duas salas aqui dentro
tem uma espécie de uma pena sozinha e
então nós que dizem num amplo bem dessa
fonte da pedra da lua é o lula essa pena
é feita de quitina a quem não é
corintiano e depois por modificação por
desastrosa do que dizem qual tanto o da
quina o que temos então o que quiser mas
também pode ser o pêlo em várias outras
shopping e por que quiseram então tão
importante porque estes grupos aqui não
interessa que não terá nada mas este
grupo de almas vim aqui quando estão
carregados
então quando estava em maio o acerto com
a mãe no nosso idioma ficam carregados
com carga positiva
ok então esta carga positiva vai
permitir as nossas micro os filhos
ficarem no fundo ligadas a um único que
nós temos no nosso tamanho é eterno
desenvolvemos então microesferas com
cerca de 150 micropontos em que sabemos
que temos aqui um
são uma uma junção dos dois dos projetos
em 71 por um lado conseguiriam ficar
tendo sucesso de tomar gol foi muito
grande muito rapidamente sobre muito
pequeninas conseguem entrar lá dentro
das celas e nós também não queremos isso
e ao mesmo tempo prometeria museu do rio
uma grande quantidade do teste então
fizemos um assunto que só eram entregues
até quem deu nos induz os times
transferências como fazemos cristo num
sonho tinha essa função quem quiser uma
solução carregadas negativamente como
que dizendo estar sentindo o leite
itália tim informa umas férias e
conseguimos ter férias com mais ronaldo
no saque
depois do vi ao finalizar scar ajuda das
minhas férias ficam como este aspecto
não cair um aspecto com uma nova textura
mais prova que vai permitir então um
futuro ligado às bactérias e confirmar
nos textos microesferas estão estáveis
em meio às 5h e não adiantaria nada tão
fazendo com que os feras que buscasse
nós também que sou de sangue que não
conseguiram vaga no técnico
confirmamos feitas muitas feiras
a maior parte delas fica ainda no
estômago - portanto os olhos e que não
eram tóxicas para as células gástricas e
vamos então com a ajuda falar de
ciências que não rezasse faço casas
nestas minhas férias e então temos aqui
as minhas férias com um dos mandas um
dos brincantes que nós temos nosso
tomamos açúcar acho que é um ex bbb e
temos outro é o selo lixo e como é que
fomos então estás essas microesferas
ligavam ligado nas bactérias disseram
específicas e não específicas para
diferentes matérias os anos bactérias
helicobacter pylori que tenham
enfrentado nas 15 não terminava a
supostamente legal o evento eu tenho a
minha essa acolhida aos eua e ao açúcar
cândido teles não acho que tenhamos duas
usinas que terão lugar nos dois do sul
caxias outras que só tem 1 e viu ligaram
como açúcar e outras que só tenha um
outro e deveriam chegar a outro e outras
que não tinham tasy nosso caminho
marcando as suas férias com o shea serão
entregues um cadastro gratuito e
conseguimos ver entanto tenhamos aqui as
nossas micro esferas tem que numa árvore
mas com várias bactérias ligadas a ela e
conseguimos mais do que isso conseguimos
ver que é ter as microesferas que não
tinham nenhum dos tais eu sou cachorro
não estávamos a popular paraense - acho
que nós temos tentado até esses
conseguiriam ligar grande quantidade de
bactérias independente dentro da usina
câmara técnica tinha hoje quando fazemos
algumas dessas tais açúcar acho que elas
olharam especificamente ao socas que
tenham como acessar as bactérias como as
tais usinas curiosas física e mental do
sul caixa que estava ter essa ligação
específica ao cair por isso com isto nós
conseguimos micro esferas como negão
todos os tempos motéis e depois
conseguimos microesferas nenhum
especificamente aquelas bactérias que
nós queremos é que vai ser a melhor de
uma bactéria não acho que o facto
consegue comover com a bactéria do do
estômago contato com a mucosa gástrica e
assim seguimos avaliar a eficiência de
uma delas e e selecionadas para provar
isso foi aqui
as microesferas como hospitais o que
acho que ela chamou de lulismo
ou seja o que nós precisávamos do humano
causa da áfrica que tivesse um revólver
para conseguir competir com as nossas
micro esferas e queremos continuar nosso
tempo uma bactéria que também tivesse
água que teria vá para ligar entre elas
então tivemos que usar mudamos para
atestar isso não podemos ficar aqui olha
tá isso quero experimentar as
microesferas incluir mesmo e outra esse
rumo olha confesso mas não funciona
assim
tivemos que arranjar mudamos para
testá-las que não começámos por fazer
uns tubo em dentro isso significa que
estamos aqui nas férias 099 não falarem
sobre o tema ambiental você vai fazer
uma biópsia e de nós podemos nunca
ninguém no estômago ou do ranking ou um
médico estava em dúvida e para financiar
dentro dos cortes histológicos muito
fininho semtran que esses corpos foram
colocados numa lâmina suns coppio
fizemos uma junta antibactéria e assim
vamos ver se conseguimos virar a bateria
estava ladeira e filha assim o fizermos
teremos então a mucosa temos várias
condições no colo com a bactéria
tenhamos ano causa como obter e depois
então a synergy todos os tipos de
microesferas ver se realmente estas
seriam os que poderiam mais e faz enfim
estão também as bactérias não prospera
juntamente com as bactérias e então
conseguimos ver aqui vocês vêem aqui e
vamos colocar zuloaga gástrica com essas
pintinhas que são as bactérias
conseguimos fazer uma quantificação do
número de bactérias pequenos em cada
área da mucosa cá estaremos numa queda
em londres e então vamos comparar com
aquilo novo com no após confusão com as
microesferas e conseguimos ver mesmo
quadro do ratinho que as microesferas
nível foram amplas remover o melhor
candidato anterior mas que dizem também
tivemos em nada também fizeram algo que
faz e nos causa - também conseguimos ver
aqui uma uma revolução nas minhas férias
de verão
até por isto estamos pelo facto ter as
muitas feiras como o açúcar chinesas que
nós temos nas nossas escolas conseguem
ajudar a remover a bateria que gostar
mas que também temos algo me faz
microesferas kits a isso é muito
interessantes mas achamos que seria
ainda mais importante mostrar isso no
verão em que tivesse um estômago real
ok então é de avançar como seu envio
porque nós não temos que não morreu em
via
permita a avaliar essas microesferas do
isep não há nenhum ratinho que consiga
ter as mesmas os mesmos locais que não
sejam infectados pelas bactérias
então queremos usar o modelo chamado ele
então podemos nem sintomas dos ratinhos
foram sacrificados como sistemas -
tomamos mesmo fizemos esse processo todo
então o que nós mesmos fizemos um
esquema mulheres e mails que tanto nas
muitas festas que fizeram com mas muitas
vezes 2010 conseguimos dar uma emoção
muito grande no banco da escola estava
doída
por fim não sei se você está em
contactos com transformar seus programas
sempre que nós tentávamos avançar com
esta nossa ideia e tentar avançar com
uma tecnologia para no segmento tentou
para entrar num mercado onde criar toda
a gente não espera um estudo sem vida
para entender como é que funciona mesmo
ainda mais um - o que quer que seja
então queríamos fazer um estudo in vivo
não conseguimos testar as tais multas
pelos números das duas bonitas que eu já
expliquei mas conseguiu conquistar
muitas coisas que estamos sozinhos que
jovens que também tenham algum efeito
então enfeitando os animais
temos alguns grupos controle externo
durante 15 dias me transferir
no fundo é um tratamento experimental
que os pais continuem altas fazendo um
time alto e usando as nossas únicas
férias em livros que havia uma moça
cerca de 63% das baterias lançado
ficamos muito contentes mas não
conseguimos ver há uma diferença muito
grande nem pensamos animais não temos em
frança está visitando seus ferimentos
significativas e achamos que mesmo assim
63% função é pouco então começarmos a
pensar que poderia estar aqui que
podemos fazer em frança
então o quando formos analisar as nossas
imagens que aumenta nossa microesfera
era um bocadinho maior outras favelas
não sei se vocês sabem mas num estilo
nós temos uma chamada de velocidade
entendo assim
as novidades a cair no estômago temos o
contrário ok temos uma linguagem das
ruas de tomar a injeção de microesferas
eram bem grande e não era não eram
suficientemente pequenas para entrar nas
investidas nas tais como velas nos toma
então queremos diminuir como cadinho
ainda as partículas e usando as peças
nacionais as microesferas fizesse essas
mãos é então incluindo os gols tomados
com as bactérias que a gente não espera
um óculo imprensa fizemos cortes
femininos e conseguimos confirmar que
menos nas várias drogas nas favelas
conseguimos ver a presença de
microesferas é que mesmo que elas fecham
este conteúdo jurídico sair com isso a
gente com 250m grau de profundidade não
estou não consigo dizer é 380.000 grande
profundidade ainda conseguimos ver ele
no finzinho da favela gasta r 950 e
micro ondas ainda conseguimos reunir as
férias por exemplo tem sido o problema
da integração não é a causa das que
estaria envolvida e por fim vamos então
fazer um estudo envolvendo coisas novas
mídias férias e vimos que com estas
brincadeiras mais meninas já conseguimos
ter uma eficiência de 90% não não até
então concluindo o fim de muitos anos
sem muito trabalho porque se anseia
não podemos tirar a primeira e temos que
estar sempre em cima dos nossos
resultados e acreditar que vamos
conseguir continuar a resolver o
problema e então conseguimos ver que
conseguimos nossas muitas férias estava
saiu a ser o que não são assim tão tocha
que até então tinha gente tomando estão
nos campinhos que elas ligam diferentes
tipos de bactérias que quando estão
modificados como esses goianos conseguem
que seja fica liberto a bactéria e
conseguimos então ver que mesmo panorama
destas duas feras fizeram parecem ser
muito promissoras como alternativa então
a apresentação das crianças e as grandes
vantagens então tanto nos destas
partículas é que não temos
anunciado anteriormente que temos um
mercado potencial muito grande na época
possa infectadas são 300 da população
sobre as duas primeiras pessoas e à faca
muita gente não tem nenhuma alternativa
para ã o de cada matéria e por isso
essas microesferas podem ser utilizadas
sozinhas ou então manter em combinação
eventualmente comuns entre outros
antibióticos para tentar melhorar a sua
eficiência e restam só agradecer aos
vários dote que me ajudaram a conseguir
este projecto e estamos agora numa fase
entanto o número sessões como indústria
bandeiras conseguimos por isso para sua
aluno não seja no futuro poderão
utilizar os tratamentos empregado